ننتقل الان الى ملف اخر يتعلق بتطورات حرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا اذ قال حاكم خرسون
الموالي لروسيا فلاديمير ساندو ان الجيش
الروسي نجح في تحيد القوات الاوكرانيه
التي عبرت الى الضفه اليسرى من نهر دنيبر
قرب جسري واكد ان القوات الروسيه باتت
تسيطر على المنطقه بشكل كامل واوضح ان
القوات الروسيه استهدفت ليله الماضيه
موقعين محصنين للقوات الاوكرانيه قرب جسر
انتونوفو ونجحت في تدميرهما والقضاء على
المجموعه العسكريه الاوكرانيه وفق قولها
ومن جهتها قالت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان القصف على انتونوف اسفر عن مقتل عدد من
المدنيين وجرح عشرات اخرين واضاف ان الجيش
الروسي غار على مواقع الجيش الاوكراني
واهداف مدنيه في كل من دنيا
وخيرسون الاستخبارات البريطانيه بدورها
قالت ان القوات الاوكرانيه استانفت بشكل
شبه مؤكد نشر الافراد على الضفه الشرقيه
لنهر بنيبره قرب جسر انت
في خرسون منذ 23 من يونيو